HOST: Kelly, Justin,
congratulations, you've
made it to the final round.
Which means you're both one
step closer to the title
of "Forged in Fire"
champion and receiving
that check for 10 grand.
Now we're sending you back
to your home forges where
we're asking you to
forge an iconic weapon
from history, the falcata.
The falcata is a curved chopping
weapon with a sharpened point.
It was popular in
pre-Roman Iberia
in what is now
Spain and Portugal.
It is unknown whether the
weapon was created in Iberia
or evolved from designs in
central Europe in Greece.
Whatever its origins, it earned
its reputation as a killer.
Employed by Spanish
infantry, that falcata
allowed its user to deliver a
blow with the force of an ax
while cutting like a sword.
Hannibal of Carthage was so
impressed by this Spanish blade
that he equipped many of
his African troops with it.
Those armed with a falcata
would rely on speed and agility
against the heavily
armored Roman soldiers.
Bladesmiths, you will have
five days to accomplish this.
At the end of those five days
you will return and present
your finished
falcatas to our panel
of expert judges, who will
then submit them to a series
of very rigorous tests.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
Here we are at my home
forge where I'm very comfy.
I love it here.
I have an awesome set of tools.
I know what glue is what.
I'm ready to roll.
I'm real comfortable
building a facata.
I like that shape of blade.
Probably the most
challenging part
is gonna be to decorate it
to where it really pops out.
I've decided since I am
a farrier that I should
probably go for the
decorative horse
heads on the end of the handle.
I'm taking a fair
amount of time to try
to get the look of this
horse down because, you know,
I want the perfect horse.
And I want the horse that
goes with that knife.
Very important to know
your horse anatomy.
He looks like he's about
a big hunk out of you.
It's going be a lot
of work but I want
to hand in the coolest project.
And I want something
that's true to the era,
but it's got a little
Kelly in it too.
[music playing]
I'm excited to be back home
with tools I'm familiar with,
but I have a big
challenge ahead of me
and some really
tough competition.
Today, I'd like to design
the blade and start forging.
I'm not a swordsmith,
I'm a bladesmith.
The falcata is a large sword,
but a big part of bladesmithing
is problem-solving.
I'm going to be
using leaf spring.
It's very thick,
it's very heavy.
It's the end of day one, what
I have is a pointy metal stick.
Tomorrow's going
to be a long day.
[music playing]
Day three, I'm feeling
really good about the progress.
Looking fine to me.
The heat treat went really well.
Everything's nice
and straight so it's
just chugging right along.
Just going to tighten up
the handle a little bit.
Historically, it kind of wraps
around and protects your hand.
I cut out a V and it's
mild steel right there,
so I'm just going to
take a little hand torch
and heat this up a little bit.
Just bend around, reweld it.
So I like the shape
of it better now.
It welded up nice.
You can't really see a seam.
I like it.
It's my last day.
I need to get a finish on this
blade, glue up the handles,
and then sharpen it.
Making a blade
this big with just
the tools I have at my
disposal is a lot of work.
But I think I did as good
a job as anybody could do,
and I feel this is
a winning weapon.
Falcata!
I think Kelly should be worried.
She's going to have to bring
a blade that can perform
just as well, or better.
Cool.
And that's quite a challenge
for anybody I believe.
JUDGE: Bladesmiths, to see
how sharp your blades are,
I will take your weapon,
and I will see how well
it does against these fish.
Kelly you're up first.
You ready?
Yep.
Going into the testing, I'm
just glad when it's over
and I'll be back to normal
Kelly not stressed-out Kelly.
Because I'm much more fun
when I'm normal Kelly.
[music playing]
JUDGE: Well, Kelly,
your blade definitely
is designed to chop through.
It cut through the first
two fish and almost
through the third one.
This will cut.
Good job.
Justin, you're up next.
You ready?
I'm ready.
JUDGE: Let's do this.
JUSTIN: Watching Kelly's blade
go through 2 and 1/2 fish
set the bar high,
and I have no idea
how this thing will perform.
[music playing]
JUDGE: Well, Justin,
your blade is sharp.
It cut all the way through
the first and second
and into the third.
It'll cut.
Next stop is a strength test.
Dave?
Smiths, on the battlefield the
falcata didn't only hit skin,
it hit other swords,
armor, and shields.
So to test the
strength of your blade,
we're going to use
our device here
to take three blows into the
steel edge of this shield.
If your blades
are made properly,
that edge should hold up.
If not, we'll see what happens.
Kelly you're up first.
You ready?
Sure.
OK.
I'm a little nervous
about the strength test.
Don't be soft piece of
garbage, just be good.
In 3, 2, 1.
3, 2, 1.
I thought I was
seeing the crack,
but it's just discoloration.
The edge held up beautifully,
it's still sharp.
All in all, held up beautifully
in the strength test.
Justin, you ready?
I'm ready.
All right.
I feel like this final
test is really going to show
what my blade's made of.
Either it's going
to hold together,
it's going to perform well,
or it may break in half.
I have no idea.
3, 2, 1.
All right, last time.
Well, I'm impressed.
No deformation, it's
still sharp, nicely done.
But that's scary.
Very scary.
It's in a position that if
blade rotates one direction,
it's going to go right
into the pad of the thumb.
It rotates the other
direction, it's
going to cut into the tendons
in the back of the hand.
That's an issue.
But all in all, it did
well in the machine.
Good job.
Thank you.
HOST: Kelly, Justin.
Before I announce the
"Forged in Fire" champion,
the judges have something they'd
like to say to both of you.
Jason?
Kelly.
One of the things that
I appreciate the most
is how you forged
the horse head.
I like the way it looked.
Also, it's traditional for a
falcata to have a horse head.
Overall it was a
beautiful piece.
Thank you.
Very nice.
HOST: Dave?
Justin, you came up
with a design there
that is a complete intimidator.
I mean, you look at that thing
and you know it's going to hurt
you if it gets close to you.
Really appreciate your
bringing something
that is solidly yours.
Means a lot, thank you.
Kelly, Justin, you've both
done very impressive work.
However, on this day, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
[music playing]
Kelly, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
[music playing]
HOST: Justin, unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut.
JUDGE: Justin, the handle is
a connection between the end
user and the blade.
Your handle construction,
with that hook being sharp,
you could potentially hurt
the person wielding it,
which, unfortunately,
prevents it from being
a fully functional weapon.
And it's for that
reason that your blade
did not make the cut.
HOST: Justin, please
surrender your weapon.
It was close.
It's nice to know that
with five days of hard work
I can impress the judges
that have seen many swords.
And I've competed
with some of the best
bladesmiths in the country.
To do that is really rewarding.
HOST: Kelly, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
You will also be receiving
a check for $10,000.
How does that make you feel?
Feels great.
DAVE: I think that
thing is great.
It's straight up right
out of the history books.
I mean, it's got all the
elements, which is really
neat, including the horse head.
HOST: It's awesome, your
our first female champion.
No, it just still
didn't seem quite real.
It feels great to be the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
The first ferrier
"Forged in Fire"
champion, the first chick
"Forged in Fire" champion.
That's pretty cool.
I pulled it off.
[music playing]